Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, Tom Holland here. This is just to warn you that this episode contains sexually sensitive content, so please do be warned. But don't necessarily be put off listening to it for that reason. I was 14 when I heard of his death. It seemed an awful calamity. I remember I rushed out of doors, sat down by myself, shouted aloud, and wrote on the sandstone, Byron is dead.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，我是汤姆·霍兰德。在此提醒您，本期节目包含性敏感内容，请务必注意。但不必因此而放弃收听。我听说他去世的消息时才14岁。那似乎是一场可怕的灾难。我记得我冲出门外，独自坐下，大声呼喊，并在砂岩上写道：拜伦死了。
So that was Alfred Lord Tennyson, the author of The Charge of the Light Brigade, poet laureate of the United Kingdom in the 19th century. And Tennyson is remembering the moment when one of his great heroes, Lord Byron, died at Missolonghi on the 19th of April, 1824, 200 years ago, Tom. 200 years ago, this coming Friday, if you're listening to this episode in the week it goes out.
那是阿尔弗雷德·丁尼生勋爵，《轻骑兵的冲锋》的作者，19世纪英国的桂冠诗人。丁尼生在回忆他的一位伟大英雄——拜伦勋爵于1824年4月19日（即200年前）在米索隆基去世的那一刻。汤姆，如果你们是在本周收听这期节目，那么这周五正好是200周年纪念日。
Crikey. And this is a very poignant moment for you because you love Lord Byron, don't you? Let's be honest. Let's just put it out there. He was my favourite poet because we should add that Missolonghi is in Greece and Byron Dye is a martyr for Greek freedom. He wrote a lot about Greece. I was very into Greece. I was very romantic. He spoke for me. And he is a figure who is not just a poet, but a kind of legend really. And so the news of his death, a martyr for Greek freedom, only 36 years old, it kind of sent shockwaves, not just across Britain, but across the whole of Europe. Because I think there's a case for saying that he is the first great international celebrity and by far the most famous British person of his day. More famous than Nelson, Tom, surely not.
天哪。这对你来说是一个非常令人感伤的时刻，因为你热爱拜伦勋爵，不是吗？老实说吧，我们直说好了。他是我的偶像诗人，因为我们应该补充一点，米索隆基在希腊，拜伦是为希腊自由而牺牲的烈士。他写了很多关于希腊的作品。我非常迷恋希腊。我曾经非常浪漫。他替我表达了心声。他不仅是一位诗人，更是一个传奇人物。因此，他作为希腊自由烈士年仅36岁就去世的消息，不仅在英国，而且在整个欧洲都引起了轰动。因为我认为有理由说，他是第一位伟大的国际名人，也是他那个时代最著名的英国人。比纳尔逊还出名，汤姆，肯定不是吧。
I guess Nelson is dead by the time that Byron has his apogée. But yes, because I think that Nelson is a national hero, but Byron is a focus for international adulation. I mean, I have to say that when I was coming back to his poetry and to his life to work out the structure for these episodes, one thing that struck me was that in many ways of all the people that we have done episodes on so far, including even John Lennon, I cannot imagine anyone who is more calculated to infuriate you than Byron. Yeah. He's the kind of anti-Dominic Sandbrook. Well, so for people who don't like one of the presenters of The Rest is History,
我想纳尔逊在拜伦达到巅峰时已经去世了。但确实如此，因为我认为纳尔逊是民族英雄，而拜伦是国际崇拜的焦点。我必须说，当我重新研读他的诗歌和生平来构思这些节目的结构时，有一件事让我印象深刻：在某种程度上，在我们迄今为止做过节目的所有人中，甚至包括约翰·列侬，我想不出还有谁比拜伦更让人恼火。是的。他简直就是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的反面。好吧，对于那些不喜欢《历史的余味》其中一位主持人的听众来说，
this will be a dream series. Yes, Tom. So I'll be honest, I approach this in a spirit of Byron phobia, but I'm prepared to be converted. You know, I'm open-minded. That said, irrespective of my own personal views about Byron, it is an extraordinary story. I mean, this series will take-minded. That said, irrespective of my own personal views about Byron, it is an extraordinary story. I mean, this series will take in, as you said,
这将会是一个梦幻系列。是的，汤姆。所以老实说，我带着一种“拜伦恐惧症”的心态来做这个节目，但我准备好被转化了。你知道，我思想很开放。话虽如此，抛开我对拜伦的个人看法，这确实是一个非凡的故事。我的意思是，这个系列将涵盖，正如你所说，
the origins of kind of celebrity culture, kind of merchandising of a personality. There's a lot of sex. So much sex. There's a lot of travel. I mean, it's like a Bond film. Every 10 minutes, we're at a different location. Albania, Greece, Constantinople.
名人文化的起源，某种人格的商品化。这里面有很多性内容。太多的性了。还有很多旅行。我的意思是，这就像一部邦德电影。每10分钟我们就换一个地点。阿尔巴尼亚、希腊、君士坦丁堡。
You know, he's going all over the Mediterranean and then back to Britain and all kinds of jumping in and out of people's beds and stuff. But it's a brilliant window, isn't it? Into the world of the kind of, I guess it's the Regency. It's what we think of as Regency Britain. Yeah, it is the Regency. And I think also what's fascinating about it is that he stands on the cusp of the regency moving into the Victorian period. And he is a focus for all kinds of moral indignation. And that also is a part of the story. It's a part of his appeal, but it's also why he is so feared and traduced. So before we start the account of his life, probably worth, just for those who don't really know very
你知道，他游历了整个地中海，然后回到英国，在各种人的床上跳进跳出之类的。但这确实是一个绝佳的窗口，不是吗？窥探那个时代，我想是摄政时期。我们认为的摄政时期的英国。是的，确实是摄政时期。而且我认为同样引人入胜的是，他正处于摄政时期向维多利亚时代过渡的关口。他是各种道德义愤的焦点。这也是故事的一部分。这是他吸引力的一部分，但也是他为何如此受人恐惧和诋毁的原因。所以在我们开始讲述他的生平之前，对于那些不太了解他的人来说，
much about him, just going through why he becomes so famous. So above all, he is a great poet. Yeah. And he is successful in a way that no poet before, or more particularly since, has ever been. I mean, poets today tend not to be rock stars. Byron was, in a way, the kind of the prototype of the rock star. So he writes this poem, Childe Harold's Pilgrimage, which is basically a kind of a travelogue. It's an account of his gap year, basically. But it's so romantic. It situates him as this kind of dark, charismatic hero at the centre of it. And the whole of Regency London
大概值得先梳理一下他为何变得如此出名。首先，他是一位伟大的诗人。是的。而且他取得的成功是前无古人，尤其是后无来者的。我的意思是，今天的诗人往往不是摇滚明星。拜伦在某种程度上是摇滚明星的原型。他写了这首诗《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》，这基本上是一种游记。基本上是他间隔年的记录。但它太浪漫了。它将他定位为处于中心位置的黑暗、迷人的英雄。整个摄政时期的伦敦
swoons over it. And Byron's famous comment on it is, I awoke one morning and found myself famous. And he's kind of like the Beatles, you know, having released She Loves You or something. The hits just keep coming. So he releases this poem called The Corsair, which again is all about a dramatic, doomed, heroic hero out in the Aegean. And that sells 10,000 copies on publication day, which is a record that still stands. I mean, no poet will ever beat that. No, because who's going to rush out and buy 10,000 copies of any poet's work these days? And the woman that he ends up marrying, and it's a disastrous marriage, but she is as obsessed by him as everyone else. And she coins this term, Byromania. So that is the prototype
都为之倾倒。拜伦对此有一句名言：我一觉醒来，发现自己出名了。他就像披头士乐队，你知道，发行了《她爱着你》之类的作品。热门作品层出不穷。于是他发行了这首名为《海盗》的诗，同样是关于爱琴海上一个戏剧性的、注定的、英勇的英雄。该诗在出版当天就卖出了1万册，这个纪录至今仍未被打破。我的意思是，没有诗人能打破这个纪录。不，因为如今谁会冲出去买1万册任何诗人的作品呢？他最终娶的那个女人，那是一场灾难性的婚姻，但她像其他人一样对他着迷。她创造了这个词：拜伦狂热（Byromania）。所以这就是
for every kind of cultural mania that has followed. And I think it's worth emphasising that he's a genuinely great poet. I mean, his best poem, Don Juan, is incredibly darkly funny. Byron is very funny as well as very romantic. I would say the most readable long poem in English. But it's not just his literary talent that makes him famous, because he is incredibly good looking. He is the embodiment of the romantic rake. And there's just a succession of aristocratic women who are swooning over him. Lady Roseberry, who almost faints when she sees him. Lady Mildmay said that when he spoke to her, her heart beat so violently that she could hardly answer him. And the aristocratic lady who becomes most notoriously obsessed by him, Caroline Lamb,
随后出现的各种文化狂热的原型。我认为值得强调的是，他确实是一位伟大的诗人。我的意思是，他最好的诗《唐璜》极其黑暗幽默。拜伦不仅非常浪漫，而且非常风趣。我会说这是英语中最具可读性的长诗。但让他出名的不仅仅是他的文学才华，因为他长得非常帅。他是浪漫浪子的化身。有一连串的贵族女性为他倾倒。罗斯伯里夫人看到他时几乎晕倒。米尔德梅夫人说，当他跟她说话时，她的心跳得如此剧烈，以至于她几乎无法回答他。而那位最臭名昭著地迷恋他的贵族女性，卡罗琳·兰姆，
she is kind of the prototype of the groupie really. The woman who becomes completely obsessed by a star and is driven to kind of madness. But the aristocratic posh groupie, right? The posh groupie. But I mean, it's not just posh groupies. So feminists also feel his allure. So Mary Shelley, the wife of Percy Shelley, of course, Mary Shelley writes Frankenstein after spending time with Byron in the year without a summer of 1816. She said of Byron, I mean, she was obsessed by him as well. There was something enchanting in his manner, his voice, his smile, a fascination in them. So, I mean, absolutely the glamour of the rock star as well as the great poet, I think. Pure charisma.
她其实就是骨肉皮（groupie）的原型。那个完全迷恋明星并陷入疯狂的女人。但她是贵族骨肉皮，对吧？贵族骨肉皮。但我的意思是，不仅仅是贵族骨肉皮。女权主义者也感受到了他的魅力。所以玛丽·雪莱，珀西·雪莱的妻子，当然，玛丽·雪莱在1816年那个“无夏之年”与拜伦共度时光后写下了《弗兰肯斯坦》。她谈到拜伦时说——我的意思是，她也对他着迷——他的举止、他的声音、他的微笑中有一种迷人的东西，一种吸引力。所以，我的意思是，绝对是摇滚明星的魅力，也是伟大诗人的魅力，我想。纯粹的魅力。
Yeah, incredible charisma. I mean, often quite dangerous charisma, incredible charisma. I mean, often quite dangerous charisma, dark charisma. I mean, no one would say he was a good man, but he's an exciting man, right? He's an exciting man. And his charisma is not just that of a poet, of course, but also that of a freedom fighter. So as we said, he dies a martyr for Greece, taking part in the Greek War of Independence that had begun in 1821 and was still raging when he dies in 1824. And although he doesn't really contribute to the campaign, he dies of fever without ever having fought a battle. His death kind of fires up Europe
是的，不可思议的魅力。我的意思是，通常是相当危险的魅力，黑暗的魅力。我的意思是，没人会说他是个好人，但他是个令人兴奋的人，对吧？他是个令人兴奋的人。而且他的魅力不仅是诗人的魅力，当然也是自由战士的魅力。正如我们所说，他作为希腊的烈士而死，参加了始于1821年并在他1824年去世时仍在进行的希腊独立战争。虽然他并没有真正为战役做出贡献，他在没有参加过一场战斗的情况下死于热病。他的死在某种程度上点燃了欧洲
to support the Greeks. It's kind of as, I don't know, as though Taylor Swift were to die a martyr for Ukraine or something like that. It's kind of on that level. It transfigures the sense of what is at stake. And Byron, to this day, is probably the most celebrated foreigner in Greece. There are statues of him everywhere, squares that are named after him, streets. So hugely popular in Greece, but also dominant. I mean, he becomes an inspirational figure to people throughout the 19th century, doesn't he? Within a year of his death in Russia, the Tsar Alexander I dies. There's a kind of an attempted liberal uprising before his heir, Nicholas I, comes to power. So the Decembrists, it's called. They all get rounded up and executed. And a volume of Byron's poetry is in the hands of one of the poets who is executed.
去支持希腊人。这就像，我不知道，就像泰勒·斯威夫特作为乌克兰的烈士而死之类的。大概是那个级别。它改变了人们对利害关系的认知。直到今天，拜伦可能仍然是希腊最受推崇的外国人。到处都有他的雕像，以他命名的广场、街道。所以在希腊非常受欢迎，而且占据主导地位。我的意思是，他成为了整个19世纪人们的灵感来源，不是吗？在他去世一年后，俄国的亚历山大一世沙皇去世。在他继任者尼古拉一世掌权之前，发生了一场未遂的自由主义起义。所以，这被称为“十二月党人起义”。他们都被围捕并处决了。其中一位被处决的诗人手中就拿着一本拜伦的诗集。
And the French painter, Eugène Delacroix, so he painted the famous picture of liberty on the barricades that people often identify with the French Revolution. He said, just remember passages from Byron when you wish to rekindle the flame. Yeah. And so, a big inspiration in the revolutions of 1848. I mean, he's the Che Guevara, really. I mean, he's a kind of an icon of cool and liberty. But you mentioned that he's also quite a bad man. So, mad bad and dangerous to know, Lady Caroline Lamb. It's her famous description of him. And Tennyson, when he is an adult, repudiates his childhood obsession with
法国画家欧仁·德拉克罗瓦，他画了那幅人们常与法国大革命联系在一起的著名画作《自由引导人民》，他说：当你想要重燃火焰时，只需记住拜伦的段落。是的。所以，他是1848年革命的一大灵感来源。我的意思是，他真的是切·格瓦拉。我的意思是，他是一种酷和自由的偶像。但你提到他也是个相当坏的人。所以，“疯狂、邪恶且危险”，卡罗琳·兰姆夫人对他的著名描述。丁尼生在成年后，否认了他童年时对
Byron. So this is the guy at the beginning who, when he was 14, shouted Byron is dead or wrote it or whatever and was so upset. And he says, actually, do you know what I've thought about it? And Byron's a terrible person. And actually in that story, you have the transition from Regency morality to Victorian morality, don't you? Because the Victorians basically thought Byron was a terrible man. I mean, he is a rake. He is a libertine. His marriage, I think beating even Ted Hughes and Sylvia Plath into second place is the most notorious in literary history. The kind of charges of sodomy and incest floating around. Yeah. You don't really want a charge of incest hanging over you, do you? Well, particularly not in the heyday of the
拜伦的痴迷。所以这就是开头提到的那个家伙，他在14岁时大喊“拜伦死了”或者写下这句话，当时非常难过。他说，其实，你知道吗，我思考过了，拜伦是个可怕的人。实际上，在那个故事中，你看到了从摄政时期道德到维多利亚时期道德的转变，不是吗？因为维多利亚时代的人基本上认为拜伦是个可怕的人。我的意思是，他是个浪子。他是个放荡不羁的人。他的婚姻，我想甚至超过了泰德·休斯和西尔维娅·普拉斯，是文学史上最臭名昭著的。关于鸡奸和乱伦的指控到处流传。是的。你真的不希望身上背负着乱伦的指控，对吧？嗯，特别是在
Victorian period. But I think the reason why, in a way, that just adds to his allure is because it kind of fuses with the element of self-portrayal in his poetry. I mentioned the corsair, this poem, the record-breaking poem. It has this couplet, he left a corsair's name to other times, linked with one virtue and a thousand crimes. But there's a sense in which actually the image of the Byronic hero is actually rather the other way around, that the Byronic hero is a man of incredible power, potency, quality, but is shadowed by a single terrible crime. And there was a very funny feature about this by Sam Leith, great writer, recently marking the anniversary in Unheard, Dominic, U-N-H-E-R-D. So I'll just read what Sam said. To be Byronic is to be willful, ardent, brooding, superhumanly attractive,
维多利亚时代的鼎盛时期。但我认为，在某种程度上，这反而增加了他的魅力，因为它与他诗歌中的自我描绘元素融合在了一起。我提到了《海盗》，这首破纪录的诗。它有这样的一联：“他给后世留下了一个海盗的名字，与一种美德和一千种罪行相连。”但有一种感觉，实际上拜伦式英雄的形象恰恰相反，拜伦式英雄是一个拥有不可思议的力量、潜能、品质的人，但被一个单一的可怕罪行所笼罩。萨姆·莱斯，伟大的作家，最近在《Unheard》杂志上发表了一篇关于这个周年纪念的非常有趣的文章，多米尼克，U-N-H-E-R-D。所以我读一下萨姆说的话。成为拜伦式的人，意味着任性、热烈、沉思、拥有超人的吸引力，
and to have a thrilling disregard for bourgeois convention. It is to be an existential hero. It is, admittedly, usually to have a flaw, but the flaw is of the ennobling tragic flaw sort, like being too tempestuous and passionate. The flaw in a Byronic hero is the sort of humble, braggery flaw that makes him, it's always him, more interesting. You'll never catch a Byronic hero is the sort of humble braggery floor that makes him it's always him more interesting you'll never catch a Byronic hero having the sort of flaws the rest of us deal with
并且对资产阶级的习俗有着令人兴奋的漠视。这是一种存在主义英雄。诚然，通常会有一个缺陷，但这个缺陷是那种高尚的悲剧性缺陷，比如过于狂暴和热情。拜伦式英雄的缺陷是那种谦逊的、吹嘘式的缺陷，这使得他——总是他——更有趣。你永远不会看到拜伦式英雄拥有我们其他人所面对的那种缺陷，
such as being a bit thick or suffering from athlete's foot Byronic heroes may be cruel and self-involved but chicks dig them so Byron I mean you mentioned at the beginning you said we've done lots of episodes and other disreputable and unpleasant characters. And you mentioned John Lennon. And this is obviously the same thing that people would say of John Lennon, isn't it? Oh yes, he's flawed, but he's so interesting and difficult and dangerous and glamorous and artistic. And his flaws, in a weird way, to his admirers, actually accentuate his appeal rather than diminish it. And that's true of Byron too, right? Yeah, but I think that Byron foregrounds the sense of danger and kind of moral danger more obviously than John Lennon.
比如有点笨或者患有脚气。拜伦式英雄可能残忍且以自我为中心，但女孩们就是喜欢他们。所以拜伦，我的意思是你在开头提到，你说我们做过很多关于其他名声不佳和令人不快的角色的节目。你提到了约翰·列侬。这显然是人们对约翰·列侬会说的话，不是吗？哦，是的，他有缺陷，但他太有趣、太复杂、太危险、太迷人、太有艺术感了。他的缺陷，以一种奇怪的方式，对他的崇拜者来说，实际上突显了他的吸引力，而不是削弱它。这对拜伦来说也是如此，对吧？是的，但我认为拜伦比约翰·列侬更明显地突显了危险感和某种道德危险。
I mean, John Lennon would always say that he was on the side of angels, just give a piece of chance. Byron is more, I mean, he's self-consciously satanic. Sympathy for the devil. Sympathy for the devil, yeah. So, I mean, it's-consciously satanic sympathy for the devil sympathy for the devil yeah so I mean it's Mick Jagger rather than John Lennon
我的意思是，约翰·列侬总是说他站在天使一边，只要给和平一个机会。拜伦更……我的意思是，他自觉地是撒旦式的。同情魔鬼。同情魔鬼，是的。所以，我的意思是，他是米克·贾格尔，而不是约翰·列侬，
who identifies with the romantic poets yeah and particularly Shelley and Byron and Byron in particular is hugely influential I would say
他认同浪漫主义诗人，是的，特别是雪莱和拜伦，尤其是拜伦，我认为他非常有影响力，
on the whole course of popular culture from his lifetime right the way up to the present day so very very obviously he's a big influence on the Brontes
对从他有生之年一直到今天整个流行文化的进程都有影响，所以非常非常明显，他是勃朗特姐妹的一大影响，
so Rochester or Heathcliff. Heathcliff, obviously, brooding, big coat, standing on moors, all that kind of stuff. Absolutely. And from them, of course, comes the matinee hero right the way into Hollywood and everything, but also a big influence on kind of the way that gay heroes are presented. So Dorian Gray is hugely influenced by Byron. And of course, the figure of the vampire, because Byron is the model for the first aristocratic vampire. So Count Dracula would be unthinkable without him. So just on the vampire, wouldn't it be a brilliant thing if somebody had written a series of novels about vampires with Lord Byron in them? It would.
所以罗切斯特或希斯克利夫。希斯克利夫，显然，沉思、大衣、站在荒原上，所有这些东西。绝对是。当然，从他们那里产生了电影明星英雄，一直到好莱坞等等，但也是对同性恋英雄呈现方式的一大影响。所以《道林·格雷的画像》深受拜伦影响。当然，还有吸血鬼的形象，因为拜伦是第一个贵族吸血鬼的原型。所以没有他，德古拉伯爵是不可想象的。关于吸血鬼，如果有人写了一系列关于吸血鬼的小说，里面有拜伦勋爵，那不是太棒了吗？确实会。
Is there such a person involved with the rest of history? Possibly. Very possibly. My first ever literary offering. Just Google Tom Holland vampire and you'll open the door to a cornucopia of delights. A can of worms. But it's also, I think, a reason for doing a series on Byron. It's his anniversary. He's a very interesting cultural figure. But also, I mean, he does hold, as you said at the start,
《历史的余味》里有这样的人吗？可能。很有可能。我的第一部文学作品。只要谷歌搜索“汤姆·霍兰德 吸血鬼”，你就会打开通往各种乐趣的大门。一个麻烦的源头。但这也是我认为制作一个关于拜伦系列的原因。这是他的周年纪念。他是一个非常有趣的文化人物。但同时，我的意思是，正如你在开头所说，他确实
a kind of a mirror up to really fascinating periods. So it is the Napoleonic era. Byron and Napoleon are often compared, not least by Byron himself. Yeah. Amazing quotation from Macaulay, Lord Macaulay, great historian. Yeah. Two men have died within our recollection who at a time of life in which few people have completed their education had raised themselves each in his own department to the height of glory. One of them died at Longwood, the other at Missolonghi. So Longwood is where Napoleon died on St Helena and Missolonghi is where Byron died.
为真正迷人的时期提供了一面镜子。所以这是拿破仑时代。拜伦和拿破仑经常被比较，不仅是拜伦本人。是的。麦考利勋爵，伟大的历史学家，有一段精彩的引语。是的。“在我们记忆中，有两个人去世了，他们在大多数人刚完成学业的年纪，就已经在各自的领域将自己提升到了荣耀的巅峰。其中一人死于朗伍德，另一人死于米索隆基。”所以朗伍德是拿破仑在圣赫勒拿岛去世的地方，而米索隆基是拜伦去世的地方。
Yeah, and both are exiles. And the point there is actually both are exiles, but also both were young. That's a really important part of Byron's legend, isn't it? He doesn't get old. He achieves extraordinary success at a very young age. And there's your kind of rock star, because film stars tend to break through very young. And often their age is part of their charisma, isn't it? Yes. And because he's the icon both of Greek nationalism and of romanticism, both of them,
是的，两人都是流亡者。重点在于，实际上两人都是流亡者，而且两人都很年轻。这是拜伦传奇中非常重要的一部分，不是吗？他没有变老。他在很年轻的时候就取得了非凡的成功。这就是你的那种摇滚明星，因为电影明星往往在很年轻时就崭露头角。而且通常他们的年龄是他们魅力的一部分，不是吗？是的。而且因为他是希腊民族主义和浪漫主义的偶像，这两者，
I think, over the course of the 19th century come to be associated with youth. And again, that's something that you very much see in the 1848 revolutions, where Byron's ghost is stalking all the episodes of that extraordinary year. So I think he is a really, really fascinating historical figure. I mean, his story is incredible and he sheds light on this really, really significant moment in European history, Napoleonic Wars and the aftermath of the Napoleonic Wars, the repression, which Byron is very opposed to, but also this shift from the Regency era, the Georgian era, the era of, you know, roistering and doistering and Jaco Macaco and all that kind of thing into the Victorian period. And the ambivalences that he creates, I think,
我认为，在19世纪的过程中都与青春联系在一起。同样，你在1848年革命中也能非常明显地看到这一点，拜伦的幽灵徘徊在那个非凡年份的所有事件中。所以我认为他是一个非常、非常迷人的历史人物。我的意思是，他的故事令人难以置信，他照亮了欧洲历史上这个非常、非常重要的时刻，拿破仑战争及其后果，拜伦非常反对的压迫，以及从摄政时期、乔治时代、那种喧闹和胡闹的时代向维多利亚时代的转变。我认为他所创造的矛盾，
are not completely gone because I think there's a temptation to think, oh, the Victorians, they're so stuffy. Ha ha. Yeah. Which is not right. Why can't they get down with it? But actually there are reasons, I think, right the way into the present day, why people would look at Byron in a slightly morally condemnatory way. And we'll touch on some of them. Yeah. So the thing about Byron is that basically everything about him is insanely melodramatic. And this is true of his ancestry. Okay. Because he's not just Byron, he is Lord Byron. He is a peer of the realm. And that also, I think, is an incredibly important part of his glamour. And Byron, even as he affected the pose of a rebel, was also very, very insistent on his rank.
并没有完全消失，因为我认为有一种诱惑会让人觉得，哦，维多利亚时代的人，他们太古板了。哈哈。这不对。为什么他们不能随和一点？但实际上，我认为直到今天，人们以一种稍微带有道德谴责的方式看待拜伦是有原因的。我们会触及其中一些。是的。所以关于拜伦的事情是，基本上关于他的一切都极其夸张。这在他的祖先身上也是如此。好吧。因为他不仅仅是拜伦，他是拜伦勋爵。他是王国的贵族。我认为这也是他魅力中极其重要的一部分。拜伦，即使他摆出反叛者的姿态，也非常、非常坚持他的等级。
And that rank derives from the fact that his ancestors had come over with William the Conqueror and had been given lands by William in the Midlands, and they settled there. And then, like so many other members of the gentry in the Reformation, they take advantage of the dissolution of the monasteries. They profiteer from Henry VIII's attack on the Catholic Church. They do. So they're in the Midlands and there is an abbey there at a place called Newstead, which in fact was not an abbey. It was an Augustinian priory that had been founded by Henry II. But it gets dissolved and it gets sold by
而这种等级源于他的祖先是随威廉征服者而来的，并被威廉授予了中部地区的土地，他们就在那里定居了。然后，像宗教改革时期的许多其他绅士成员一样，他们利用了修道院解散的机会。他们从亨利八世对天主教会的攻击中牟取暴利。他们确实这样做了。所以他们在中部地区，那里有一个叫纽斯特德的地方有一座修道院，事实上那不是修道院。那是由亨利二世建立的奥古斯丁修道院。但它被解散了，并被
henry viii's agents in 1540 to sir john byron and the byrons settle in newstead abbey and they leave a large section of the abbey basically just to decay so they build their house in the middle of it but there are whole sections yeah and in time, this will make it everything that the romantics adore. The sense of, you know, bare ruined choirs, all that kind of thing. Right. I have to say, Tom, it's not in a terribly romantic part of the country. So it's near Mansfield, isn't it? Sort of Nottinghamshire mining country.
亨利八世的代理人在1540年卖给了约翰·拜伦爵士，拜伦家族在纽斯特德修道院定居，他们基本上让修道院的大部分区域任其腐朽，所以他们在中间建造了自己的房子，但有整个区域。随着时间的推移，这将使它成为浪漫主义者所崇拜的一切。那种“光秃秃的废墟唱诗班”的感觉，所有这些东西。对。我必须说，汤姆，它不在这个国家非常浪漫的地方。所以它靠近曼斯菲尔德，对吧？诺丁汉郡的矿区。
Yeah, that's right. And not a place that you would normally identify with romance and glamour. I don't want to offend our listeners from Nottinghamshire. But as we will see, mining actually plays quite an important part in this story. Oh, tantalising. Because it comes with the lands on which there are quite a lot of coal mines. Okay. So that's a source of his wealth. So the first Lord Byron is created in 1643,
是的，没错。这不是一个你通常会与浪漫和魅力联系在一起的地方。我不想冒犯我们诺丁汉郡的听众。但正如我们将看到的，采矿实际上在这个故事中扮演了相当重要的角色。哦，真诱人。因为它附带了土地，上面有很多煤矿。好吧。所以那是他财富的来源。所以第一位拜伦勋爵是在1643年被封的，
which of course is when the Civil War is being fought. The guy who becomes Sir John Byron, who becomes Lord Byron, he's fighting on the side of the king. And he's given his peerage as a reward for his valour at the first battle of Newbury. And he then commands the right wing at Marston Moor, not to any great effect. Because of course the royalists lose Marston Moor. And when the king is defeated, he goes into exile. So prefiguring what will happen to his descendant. And he dies in Paris in 1652. So it's heroism, but kind of faintly hapless heroism.
当然，那时内战正在进行。那个成为约翰·拜伦爵士，后来成为拜伦勋爵的人，他站在国王一边战斗。他被授予爵位作为他在纽伯里第一次战役中英勇表现的奖励。然后他在马斯顿荒原战役中指挥右翼，但没有产生什么重大影响。因为当然保皇党输掉了马斯顿荒原战役。当国王战败时，他流亡了。所以预示了后来发生在他后代身上的事情。他于1652年在巴黎去世。所以这是英雄主义，但是一种淡淡的、不幸的英雄主义。
Right. And that's a tradition that continues because Lord Byron's grandfather, the poet's grandfather, is probably after Byron the most famous of his family. He's a very entertaining person, I think. He is. So he's the second son of the fourth Lord Byron, and he joins the Navy. We're now in the 18th century, so the heyday of the rise of the Navy to global power. Yeah. Royal Britannia, Heart of Oak, people eating roast beef on ships, all that. Yes. So he joins as a midshipman rises up through the ranks and he has a slightly
对。这是一个持续的传统，因为拜伦勋爵的祖父，这位诗人的祖父，可能是拜伦之后他家族中最著名的人。他是一个非常有趣的人，我想。他是。所以他是第四代拜伦勋爵的次子，他加入了海军。我们现在是在18世纪，所以是海军崛起为全球力量的鼎盛时期。是的。不列颠尼亚，橡木之心，人们在船上吃烤牛肉，所有这些。是的。所以他作为海军见习生加入，一路晋升，他有一个稍微
unfortunate name of foul weather jack well that's his nickname not his name you wouldn't name somebody foul weather as they know so the ship that he joins as midshipman it's been the subject of a very good book recently yeah by david gran who also wrote killers of the flat moon the thing that inspired the film, yeah. Very successful American non-fiction writer. Yeah. So the guy who will come to be nicknamed Foulweather Jack joins it in 1740,
不幸的名字叫“坏天气杰克”。好吧，那是他的绰号，不是他的名字，你不会给某人起名叫“坏天气”的，正如他们所知。所以他作为见习生加入的那艘船，最近是一本非常好的书的主题，是的，由大卫·格兰所写，他也写了《花月杀手》，启发了那部电影的东西，是的。非常成功的美国非小说作家。是的。所以那个后来被称为“坏天气杰克”的家伙在1740年加入了它，
and the HMS Wager is going around the world. And in 1741, it is shipwrecked on an island of Patagonia. Yeah. And Foulweather Jack is one of 19 men who get into a lifeboat, and they're cast adrift and he has taken with him his little pet dog and the pet dog gets eaten by the starving men and byron adapts this as an episode in his his great poem don jewin on the sixth day they fed upon his hide and jewin who had still refused because the creature was his father's dog that died,
而“威格号”正在环游世界。1741年，它在巴塔哥尼亚的一个岛屿上沉没了。是的。“坏天气杰克”是19名登上救生艇的人之一，他们被抛弃在海上，他随身带着他的小宠物狗，那只宠物狗被饥饿的人们吃掉了，拜伦在他的伟大诗作《唐璜》中改编了这个情节：“第六天，他们吃掉了它的皮，而唐璜，因为那生物是他父亲死去的狗，仍然拒绝，现在感到下颚里充满了秃鹫的贪婪，带着一些悔恨接受了，他们首先作为一种巨大的恩惠，拒绝了四只爪子中的一只，他把它分给了佩德里洛，佩德里洛狼吞虎咽地吃了下去，渴望着另外两只。”佩德里洛是唐璜的导师，后来也会被这些人吃掉。多米尼克，这也是帕特里克·奥布莱恩的小说《未知的海岸》的灵感来源，所以那是奥布里-马图林在《怒海争锋》系列中的前身，不是吗？所以有些人说那本书中的关系预示了罗素·克劳和保罗·贝坦尼饰演的马图林，总之那是题外话，对吧？但整个帕特里克·奥布莱恩皇家海军之类的东西，我的意思是这非常是“坏天气杰克”所属的世界。他做得非常好。他在七年战争中
now feeling all the vulture in his jaws, with some remorse received, they first denied, as a great favour, one of the four paws, which he divided with Pedrillo, who devoured it, longing for the other two. Pedrillo is Juin's tutor, who in due course will be eaten by the men. And Dominic, this is also the inspiration for patrick o'brien's novel the unknown shore so that was a precursor wasn't it of the auburn matter in master and commander series so some people say the relationship in that book anticipates russell crowe and who's mattering paul bettany anyway that's by the by right but the whole um patrick o'brien royal navy all that kind of thing i mean this is very much the world that Fowler Jack is part of. And he does tremendously well. He does a heroic service in the Seven Years
立下了英勇的功勋，最终在独立战争期间指挥美国海域的英国海军，有九个孩子，并于1786年在父亲之前去世。所以他实际上从未成为拜伦勋爵。相反，成为新拜伦勋爵的人，即第五代拜伦勋爵，是他的弟弟威廉，他也曾出海，但在继承爵位后就放弃了。他被称为“邪恶勋爵”。而“邪恶勋爵”，为了把这个放到背景中，邪恶勋爵是你拜伦勋爵的叔祖父。对吗？那是对的。好吧。是的。所以邪恶勋爵，
War, ends up commanding the British Navy in American waters during the War of Independence, has nine children, and dies in 1786 before his father. So he never actually becomes Lord Byron. And instead, the person who becomes the new Lord Byron, the fifth Lord Byron, is his younger brother, William, who also goes to sea, but then gives it up when he inherits the title. And he is known as the Wicked Lord. And the Wicked Lord, so just to get this into context, the Wicked Lord is your Lord Byron's great uncle. Is that right? That's right. Okay. Yes. So the wicked Lord,
为什么是邪恶勋爵？好吧，因为他在一场斗殴中杀了一个邻居。好吧。在伦敦帕尔摩尔的一家酒馆里。好吧。据说他在纽斯特德修道院组织狂欢，枪杀了他的马车夫，通过把他扔进湖里谋杀了他的妻子。我认为这些都不是真的，但这反映了他的名声。哦不，但你认为我们无论如何都要把它加进去，只是为了抹黑他的名字。他钱花得很快，砍伐了纽斯特德修道院周围森林里的所有树木作为木材，卖掉了房产里的一切，从画作到牙签。他以60英镑的年租金租出了兰开夏郡罗奇代尔的2万英亩煤矿，这显然是一笔糟糕的交易，同样，金钱烦恼将成为
why the wicked Lord? Well, because he kills a neighbour in a brawl. Okay. In a tavern on Pall Mall in London. Okay. He's said to have organised orgies at Newstead Abbey, to have shot his coachman dead, to have murdered his wife by throwing her into the lake. None of which I think is actually true, but it's kind of reflective of his reputation. Oh no, but you thought we'd throw it in there anyway, just to muddy his name. He runs badly out of money, chops down all the wood in the woods around Newstead Abbey for timber, flogs off everything in the property from paintings to toothpicks. And he leases 20,000 acres of coal mines in Rochdale in lancashire for 60 pounds annual rent which is obviously a terrible deal and again money worries will be a shadow over
诗人生活中的阴影，对吧，因为显然，你知道，他挥霍遗产的事实对任何将要继承他的人来说都不是好消息。现在，坏天气杰克的长子，也就是诗人的父亲，所以他也有一个绰号，叫“疯狂杰克”。疯狂杰克。我们有一个疯狂杰克，一个邪恶勋爵和一个坏天气杰克。是的，我们现在到了疯狂杰克，他基本上是一个现实生活中的威克姆先生。好吧。在《傲慢与偏见》中，那个和莉迪亚私奔的无赖。是的，疯狂杰克，我的意思是，他比无赖更糟，我会说他是一个流氓，一个烂人，一个烂人。好吧。他是个烂人，对吧？所以他去了威斯敏斯特，无可救药。是的，被送到巴黎的军事学校，在那里他过得很愉快，穿着制服到处招摇，冷酷无情，和人鬼混，你知道，
the poet's life right right because obviously you know the fact that he is burning through the inheritance is not good news for whoever's going to succeed him now what a foul weather jack's elder son who is the father of the poet so he he also has a nickname it's mad jack mad jack we've got a mad jack a wicked lord and foul weather jack yeah we're now onto mad jack and he's basically a real life mr wickham okay so in pride and prejudice the cad who runs off with lydia yeah and mad jack i mean he's worse than a cad i'd say he's a bounder a rotter a rotter okay he's a rotter right so he goes to westminster hopeless yeah gets sent to military school in paris where he has a lovely time kind of swagging around in his uniform being heartless and getting off with people and you know
诱惑他们然后甩掉他们。他非常擅长赌债，他的父母最终切断了他的经济来源，因为他挥霍了太多的钱，所以他成了一个男妓，就像一个职业男妓。是的，职业男妓，就像金钱易手。是的，哇，好吧。但他一直在寻找女继承人。是的，1778年，他遇到了乔治·奥斯本（前财政大臣和播客主持人）的一位非常遥远的祖先，名叫阿米莉亚·奥斯本，她是卡马森侯爵的妻子。疯狂杰克和阿米莉亚·奥斯本私奔了，他们在法国定居。他们有三个孩子。其中两个死了，但其中一个，一个叫奥古斯塔的女孩，活到了成年。但阿米莉亚·奥斯本很快就去世了。她死于1784年。有传言说是她丈夫的虐待，但拜伦，公平地说，
seducing them and dumping them he's a great one for gambling debts his parents end up cutting him off because he's burnt through so much money and so he becomes a gigolo like a professional gigolo yeah professional gigolo like money changes hands yeah wow okay but all the time he's looking around for an heiress yeah and in 1778 he meets with a very distant ancestor of George Osborne, the former Chancellor of the Exchequer and the pod show host, who's called Amelia Osborne, who is the wife of the Marquess of Carmarthen. Mad Jack and Amelia Osborne elope and they settle in France. They have three children. Two of them die, but one of them, a girl called Augusta, survives to adulthood. But Amelia Osborne dies very soon afterwards. She dies in 1784. It is rumoured of ill usage from her husband, but Byron, it is fair to say,
总是为他的父亲辩护，评论道：“一个年轻的卫队军官诱惑并带走一位侯爵夫人，并娶了两位女继承人，这并非靠残暴。确实，他是一个非常英俊的男人，这很有帮助。”那是一个糟糕的借口。我的意思是，我认为那是一个可悲的借口。我的意思是，他完全有可能虐待了他的妻子，但仍然非常英俊。我的意思是，这两件事并不是……我知道，但拜伦在为他爸爸说话，这很感人。好吧，没问题。所以他爸爸疯狂杰克有一个叫奥古斯塔的女孩，他儿子的妻子。是的，拜伦勋爵还没有进入故事，所以我假设他再婚了。是的，所以拜伦在那个评论中说他娶了两位女继承人，所以第二位女继承人是他在巴斯遇到的某个人。所以当
always defended his father, commented, it is not by brutality that a young officer in the guard seduces and carries off a marchioness and marries two heiresses it is true that he was a very handsome man which goes a long way that's a terrible excuse i mean i think that's a pathetic excuse i mean it's perfectly possible he could have abused his wife and yet been very handsome i mean those two things are not i know but byron's sticking up for his dad that's touching okay fine so his dad mad jack has got one girl called augusta and his son's a wife yeah and lord byron has yet to enter the story so i'm going to assume that he marries again yeah so byron in that comment said that he'd married two heiresses so the second heiress is someone who he meets in bath so the moment that
他的第一任妻子去世后，他回到英国，去了巴斯。当然。正如所有简·奥斯汀的读者都知道的那样，那是你去的地方。那是婚姻市场。是的。在那里他遇到了年轻的苏格兰女继承人凯瑟琳·戈登，
his first wife is dead he comes back to England, goes to Bath. Of course. Which, as all readers of Jane Austen will know, that is where you go. That's the marriage market. Yeah. And there he meets with a young Scottish heiress, Catherine Gordon,
她是吉特庄园（靠近阿伯丁）的女继承人。对。公平地说，她比卡马森侯爵夫人要少得多魅力。我可以看到笔记中盯着我的词。邋遢、摇摆、平庸。那太刻薄了。
who is heiress to the estates of Gite, which is near Aberdeen. Right. And she, it is fair to say, is considerably less glamorous than the Marchioness of Cormoran. I can see the words staring out at me from the notes. Frumpish, waddling, plain. That's harsh.
而且乡土气、社交笨拙。那么是什么吸引了疯狂杰克……哦，是的，吉特庄园。富有的女继承人。吉特庄园。所以他娶这个女人纯粹是为了她的钱。纯粹为了她的钱，是的。他们一结婚，他们就在巴斯结婚，她立刻开始
And provincial and socially awkward. So what was it attracted, Mad Jack, to the... Oh yes, the estates of Gite. The wealthy heiress. Estates of Gite. So he mirrors this woman purely for her money. Purely for her money, yes. And the moment they've got married and they get married in Bath, she immediately starts
变卖她的遗产来偿还她丈夫的债务。哦，这太糟糕了。我的意思是，这对于任何读过19世纪小说的人来说都太熟悉了。是的。那个被无赖诱惑然后他挥霍了她所有钱的笨拙、不幸的乡下女孩。我为她感到难过，你知道，她很快就怀孕了，你知道，他挥霍她的钱如此之快，以至于在她分娩之前，她的丈夫就不得不向他的裁缝借钱，
selling off her inheritance to pay off her husband's debts. Oh, this is all very bad. And I mean, this is so familiar from anyone who's ever read a 19th century novel. Yeah. You know, the gauche, hapless provincial girl who gets seduced by the cad and then he squanders all her money. I feel sorry for her some and you know she gets pregnant very quickly and you know he blows her money so quickly that even before she's given birth her husband is is having to borrow money from his tailor
极其羞辱。是的，并逃往法国。凯瑟琳不得不搬家，我的意思是，这太令人震惊了，她不得不搬进一家商店上面的公寓，她在卡文迪什广场就这样做了。在马里波恩，是的。那就是1788年1月22日，乔治·戈登·拜伦，她的儿子出生的地方。所以戈登来自她的家族，显然是一个苏格兰名字。是的。关于拜伦的一个快速问题，他是否认为自己是苏格兰人？我们会谈到这一点。
incredibly humiliating yeah and flee to france and Catherine has to move, I mean, it's shocking, she has to move into a flat above a shop, which she does in Cavendish Square. In Marleybone, yeah. And that is where, on the 22nd of January, 1788, George Gordon Byron is born, her son. So Gordon comes from her family, obviously a Scottish name. Yes. Quick question about Byron, does he ever think of himself as Scottish? We'll come to that.
好吧，哦，令人兴奋。这是一个非常有趣的问题。是的。关于拜伦的一个快速问题。他是否认为自己是苏格兰人？我们会谈到这一点。好吧。哦，令人兴奋。这是一个非常有趣的问题。好吧。所以他出生时患有马蹄内翻足，他们真的负担不起治疗费用。后来在生活中，他会对这一点感到非常怨恨。他会觉得是母亲的错，导致这个马蹄内翻足没有治愈。好吧。他开始把它看作是一种将他与众不同的标志。这是一种撒旦的印记。该隐的印记之类的东西。该隐的印记。但他有一种感觉，即使他被它折磨，他也觉得它在某种程度上将他提升到了普通人之上。这是某种标志着他与众不同的东西。而他出生时没有可能得到适当医疗治疗的原因是因为显然爸爸不在那里，因为爸爸在外面
Okay, oh, exciting. It's a very interesting question. Yes. Quick question about Byron. Does he ever think of himself as Scottish? We'll come to that. Okay. Oh, exciting. It's a very interesting question. Okay. So he is born with a club foot and they can't really afford the treatment for it. And later in life, he'll be very resentful of this. He will feel that it was his mother's fault that this club foot wasn't cured. Okay. And he comes to see it as a kind of a marker of what sets him apart. It's a kind of a satanic stamp. The mark of Cain kind of thing. The mark of Cain. But he kind of feels, even as he is tortured by it, he also feels that it kind of elevates him above the common run. It's something that marks him as different. And the reason that there is no possibility of kind of getting proper medical treatment for it the moment he's born is because obviously daddy isn't there because daddy is off
躲避法警。坦率地说，我认为责怪他的母亲而不是他的父亲是相当苛刻的。这非常苛刻。我想这是因为基本上爸爸几乎不在那里。所以拜伦不了解他，而他有很多空间去责怪他的母亲，因为他的母亲总是在那里。无论如何，他们从伦敦搬到了阿伯丁，因为那是在苏格兰。因此，根据苏格兰法律，杰克不能因为在英国欠下的债务而被捕。这显然是一场彻底的噩梦。杰克·拜伦去那里和他妻子团聚。但同样，他们几乎没有钱，所以他们不得不再次住进一家商店上面的公寓。为了增加乐趣，他们有一个严厉的加尔文教派的保姆叫艾格尼丝·格雷，她让一切变得糟糕。他们无休止地争吵。拜伦的母亲有点
dodging the bailiffs. I think it's pretty harsh to blame his mother and not his father for it, frankly. It is very harsh. I guess it's because basically daddy is barely there. So Byron doesn't know him where he has lots of scope to blame his mother because his mother is always there. Anyway, they move from London to Aberdeen because that's in Scotland. And so therefore, under Scottish law, Jack can't be arrested for debts accrued in England. And it's obviously a complete nightmare. Jack Byron comes and joins his wife there. But again, they have so little money that they have to, again, live in a flat above a shop. And just to add to the fun, they have a sternly Calvinist nursemaid called Agnes Grey, who just makes it terrible. They're endlessly rowing. Byron's mother is kind of
总是对他发脾气，叫他“该死的瘸子”，然后又用吻淹没他。杰克正在榨干她的每一分钱。然后他消失在法国，多米尼克，他在那里与他的妹妹发生了婚外情。好吧。停在那里，汤姆。更多的乱伦将出现在这个播客中。拜伦家族和乱伦是怎么回事？他为什么要和他的妹妹睡觉？我不知道。我的意思是，她有很多钱。他认识她。那不是原因。好吧，是因为他几乎没有钱。谁能拿到钱。那没关系。但我的意思是，对于他的妹妹来说，说“听着，这是我保释你的条件”似乎很奇怪。我的意思是，那不正常。
always losing her temper with him, calling him a damned lame brat and then smothering him in kisses. Jack is leeching her out of every last penny. He then vanishes to France, where Dominic, he embarks on an affair with his sister. Okay. Stop right there, Tom. More incest will feature in this podcast. What is it about the Byrons and incest? Why is he sleeping with his sister? I don't know. I mean, she has lots of money. He knows her. That's not the reason. Well, it is because he has so little money. Whoever can get the money off. That's fine. But I mean, it seems weird for his sister to say, listen, it's a condition of me bailing you out. I mean, that's not normal.
我同意。这绝对不是你在奇平诺顿会有的那种行为。我完全接受这一点。但如果你是一个疯狂的浪子，那就是你会做的事情。但无论如何，妹妹去了巴斯，把杰克留在了那里，他太穷了。他开始咳血，可能死于肺结核。拜伦认为他割断了自己的喉咙，但可能没有。他在1791年去世了。我的意思是，他在恐怖统治的鼎盛时期在法国，所有这些。是的。
I agree. It's very much not the kind of behavior that you get in Chipping Norton. I entirely accept that. But it's the kind of thing that if you're a mad rake, that's what you do. But anyway, the sister goes off to bath, leaves Jack there, and he's so skint. He starts coughing up blood, probably dies of TB. Byron thinks that he'd slit his throat, but probably not. And he is dead by 1791. I mean, he's in France at the heyday of the terror and everything. Yeah.
但他显然还有其他事情要考虑。是的。所有这一切的结果是，由于他的马蹄内翻足，他父亲离开，和妹妹睡觉，咳血，可能自杀。拜伦觉得他有一个被诅咒的遗产。好吧，我认为公平地说，他的人生开端并不理想，不是吗，汤姆？而且事情实际上变得更糟了，令人兴奋的是。
But he obviously has other things on his mind. Yeah. And the consequence of all this is with his club foot, his father going off, sleeping with his sister, coughing up blood, possibly killing himself. Byron feels that he has a cursed inheritance. Well, I think it's fair to say he hasn't had the ideal start in life, isn't it, Tom? And things actually get worse, excitingly.
但他显然还有别的心事。是的。这一切的结果就是，他天生内翻足，父亲离家出走，与亲姐妹乱伦，咳血，甚至可能自杀。拜伦觉得他背负着被诅咒的家世。汤姆，我想说他的人生开局确实不太理想，对吧？而且更令人兴奋的是，情况还会变得更糟。
So we'll return after the break to see how things could possibly get worse for him. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
那么休息过后，我们将回来看看他的处境还能糟糕到什么地步。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the life of George Gordon Byron, Lord Byron, great rake, great poet, great character, an international celebrity of the early 19th century. Tom, his childhood so far has had something of the Victorian novel about it and actually becomes even more Victorian novel after his father's death, doesn't it?
以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余谈》。我们正在讨论乔治·戈登·拜伦，即拜伦勋爵的一生，他是一位伟大的浪子、伟大的诗人、伟大的人物，也是19世纪初的国际名人。汤姆，他迄今为止的童年生活带有一种维多利亚时代小说的色彩，而且在他父亲去世后，这种色彩变得更加浓厚了，不是吗？
Yeah, because they're stranded in Aberdeen. You know, this little boy growing up there with his mother who's been fleeced by his father and this stern Calvinist nursemaid, Agnes Grey. And it's awful, basically. They're very poor. He has very kind of rudimentary schooling. It all looks awful. But then, great expectations. Because what happens is that the wicked law's heir is only surviving grandson. So that's Byron's cousin, I'm guessing. Second cousin or something, would it? I don't know. It's all very confusing.
是的，因为他们被困在阿伯丁。你知道，这个小男孩和被他父亲榨干了钱财的母亲，以及那位严厉的加尔文教派保姆艾格尼丝·格雷住在一起。这简直太糟糕了。他们非常贫穷。他只接受了非常基础的教育。这一切看起来都很糟糕。但随后，伟大的期望出现了。因为发生的事情是，那位邪恶勋爵的继承人是他唯一的在世孙子。所以我猜那是拜伦的表亲。堂表亲之类的，是吗？我不知道。这太令人困惑了。
Okay. But basically, as it stands, Byron is not going to succeed because the wicked Lord has a grandson. But then this grandson gets killed at the siege of Calvi in 1794, which is the same one that Nelson loses his eye at, I think, isn't it? Yeah. Hit by spinsters in his eye, shrapnel. Yeah. So this is on Corsica. The British are trying to capture Corsica.
好吧。但基本上，就目前的情况来看，拜伦不会继承爵位，因为那位邪恶的勋爵有一个孙子。但后来这个孙子在1794年的卡尔维围城战中阵亡了，我想那也是纳尔逊失去眼睛的那场战役，对吧？是的。被弹片击中了眼睛。是的。所以这是在科西嘉岛。英国人当时正试图占领科西嘉岛。
They're trying to get a Mediterranean base in 1794. They're fighting the French Revolutionary Forces. They actually do capture Calvi, but this guy is killed. Yeah. And Byron is now in prime position to inherit what is left of the estate. He is the heir. Right. And so immediately, you know, his prospects have massively brightened.
他们在1794年试图获得一个地中海基地。他们正在与法国革命军作战。他们确实占领了卡尔维，但这家伙被杀了。是的。而拜伦现在处于继承剩余遗产的最佳位置。他是继承人。没错。所以他的前景立刻变得一片光明。
He's moved to the grammar school, gets much better education. And because he now knows that he's going to become a lord, I think he starts kind of chafing against what he sees as the provincialism of Aberdeen. And he escapes it in two ways. One by, he comes to love the grandeur of the mountains around him. He sees rugged terrain as an escape from, you know, the shop and the nursery maid and all that kind of thing. Which is very 1790s, isn't it?
他转学到了文法学校，接受了更好的教育。而且因为他现在知道自己将成为一名勋爵，我想他开始对阿伯丁的狭隘感到不满。他通过两种方式逃避了这种环境。第一，他开始热爱周围山脉的壮丽。他将崎岖的地形视为逃离商店、保姆和所有那些琐事的一种方式。这非常有1790年代的风格，不是吗？
Unbelievably 1790s. I mean, the love of nature and the great vistas and brooding thoughts out on the craggy hills and all that stuff. All that kind of thing. Yeah. But also very 1790s is losing yourself in books because this is exactly what Napoleon did. So like Napoleon, Byron is obsessed by Roman history, but also by Oriental history.
难以置信的1790年代风格。我是说，对自然的热爱、宏伟的远景、在崎岖山丘上的沉思等等。所有这些。是的。但同样非常1790年代的是沉浸在书本中，因为这正是拿破仑所做的。所以像拿破仑一样，拜伦痴迷于罗马历史，也痴迷于东方历史。
So he loves travel accounts of people going to the Ottoman Empire, say, or to Greece or wherever. Yeah. And he loves the Arabian Nights. And this is a fascination that will be with him forever. A taste for the exotic, I guess it's fair to say. Yeah. And then comes the moment they've all been waiting for, 19th of May, 1798, the death of the wicked Lord. And he leaves so little money that actually it's a bit of an effort
所以他喜欢阅读人们前往奥斯曼帝国、希腊或其他地方的游记。是的。而且他喜欢《一千零一夜》。这种迷恋将伴随他一生。我想说，这是一种对异国情调的品味。是的。然后他们期待已久的时刻到来了，1798年5月19日，邪恶勋爵去世了。他留下的钱很少，以至于
for Byron's mother, Catherine, to scrape the money together. But they get it, get into a stage coach, head down to Nottinghamshire, move to Newstead Abbey, and it's basically a ruin. The Wicked Lord has not been a dab hand at the DIY, I think it's fair to say. But to the newly elevated Lord Byron, it's absolutely thrilling. He's 10 years old. He's inherited this kind of broken down ruin. I mean, unbelievably exciting. Right. He's got this kind of broken down ruin. I mean, unbelievably exciting. Right.
拜伦的母亲凯瑟琳要凑齐这笔钱都费了一番功夫。但他们还是凑到了钱，坐上驿站马车，前往诺丁汉郡，搬进了纽斯特修道院，那里基本上是一片废墟。我想说，这位邪恶的勋爵并不擅长修缮房屋。但对于新晋的拜伦勋爵来说，这绝对令人兴奋。他才10岁。他继承了这种破败的废墟。我的意思是，难以置信地令人兴奋。没错。他得到了这种破败的废墟。我的意思是，难以置信地令人兴奋。没错。
He's got a bit of a couplet here, haven't you? A nice poem. Through thy battlements, Newstead, the hollow winds whistle. Thou, the hall of my fathers, art gone to decay. This is the kind of poetry he writes to begin with. It's very kind of melodramatic, but you could see why. Yeah. So slightly gothic.
你这里有一句对联，对吧？一首不错的诗。纽斯特，穿过你的城垛，空洞的风在呼啸。我祖先的大厅，已走向衰败。这就是他最初写的诗。非常感伤，但你能明白为什么。是的。所以有点哥特式。
It's a gothic scene. Completely gothic. I mean, this is the age of the gothic, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. Sort of bare ruined choirs, memories of the past, the wind howling, all that business. Yes. But his affairs are in an absolute mess. And he has this lawyer, John Hanson, who in time will show himself to be rather sinister. But he's trying to get it all in order, try and raise some money, which he does pretty effectively.
这是一个哥特式的场景。完全是哥特式的。我的意思是，这是哥特式的时代，不是吗？是的，绝对是。那种荒凉的废墟、对过去的记忆、风的呼啸，所有这些。是的。但他的事务一团糟。他有一位律师，约翰·汉森，后来证明他相当阴险。但他正试图把一切理顺，设法筹集一些资金，他做得相当有效。
And Byron's mother stays at Newstead, but Byron himself is taken out because it's felt that this isn't a good place for a boy to be growing up. He's only 10, right? I mean, it'd be mad for him to be there. So he is sent to Nottingham to live with Agnes Grey, the Bible-thumping nursemaid. Yeah. Who nevertheless turns out to be very badly behaved. So despite her stern Calvinism, she's actually spending all her time getting drunk and having flings with coachmen. And then she starts sexually abusing the young Byron. Okay.
拜伦的母亲留在了纽斯特，但拜伦本人被带走了，因为人们觉得这里不适合一个男孩成长。他才10岁，对吧？我的意思是，让他待在那里简直是疯了。所以他被送到诺丁汉，和那位大谈圣经的保姆艾格尼丝·格雷住在一起。是的。但她后来表现得非常糟糕。所以尽管她有严厉的加尔文教派信仰，但她实际上把所有时间都花在酗酒和与马车夫调情上。然后她开始性虐待年幼的拜伦。好吧。
What on earth is going on there? He's 10. When you say she's sexually abusing him, I mean. She starts masturbating him. Manipulating him. Yeah. Messing around with him. Yeah.
那到底是怎么回事？他才10岁。当你说是性虐待时，我的意思是。她开始对他进行手淫。操纵他。是的。对他动手动脚。是的。
And he doesn't want this to happen? It's against his will? Well, I mean, it has a seismic influence on him. Yeah. I mean, so firstly, he comes to associate Christianity with hypocrisy and cant. Not unreasonably in her case. Absolutely. Because, you know, she's speaking the Bible while she's fiddling around with him.
他不希望发生这种事？这是违背他意愿的？嗯，我的意思是，这对他的影响是巨大的。是的。我的意思是，首先，他开始将基督教与虚伪和空谈联系起来。在她的案例中，这并非没有道理。绝对是。因为，你知道，她一边念着圣经，一边对他动手动脚。
Yes. But I think it also leaves him with kind of tortured, ambivalent attitudes to women. Yeah, of course. Feeling that they can't really be trusted. Yeah. And he reflects about the impact of it on him shortly before he dies, you know, years later. And he says, my passions were developed very early, so early that few would believe me if I were to state the period and the facts which accompanied it. Perhaps this was one of the reasons which caused the anticipated melancholy of my thoughts, having anticipated life.
是的。但我认为这也让他对女性产生了某种痛苦、矛盾的态度。是的，当然。觉得她们真的不可信。是的。他在去世前不久，也就是多年后，反思了这件事对他的影响。他说，我的激情发展得非常早，早到如果我说出那个时期以及伴随它的事实，很少有人会相信我。也许这就是导致我思想中那种预期的忧郁的原因之一，因为我预支了生活。
He's probably, what, 11, 12 when this is happening? Yeah, and he's very much not Byronic at this point. He's kind of fat. He's bashful he's shy and his neighbors so they're in provincial england they see him as provincial yeah so he's in a bad way really so tom i have to say having disloyal byron earlier on i feel sorry for him that because this is a terrible thing to have happened to him but also dominic the other thing that you'd like about what happens next is that Hanson's solution
发生这件事时他大概几岁，11、12岁？是的，而且他此时一点也不像拜伦。他有点胖。他害羞、腼腆，他的邻居们，也就是在英国的省份里，认为他很土气。是的。所以他真的处境很糟糕。所以汤姆，我不得不说，在之前贬低了拜伦之后，我为他感到难过，因为这对他来说是一件可怕的事情。但多米尼克，你也会喜欢接下来发生的事情，那就是汉森的解决方案
is to send him to a private school. I applaud that. You applaud that. Yeah. So Byron gets sent to Harrow in April 1881. So he's going up in the world. Yeah.
是把他送到一所私立学校。我对此表示赞赏。你赞赏这个。是的。所以拜伦在1881年4月被送到了哈罗公学。所以他正在步步高升。是的。
And obviously he hates it at first because he has a club foot. I was about to say, if you've got a club foot, going to a Regency-era boarding school is probably not ideal. It's not. Yeah, it's not ideal.
显然他起初很讨厌那里，因为他有内翻足。我正想说，如果你有内翻足，去一所摄政时代的寄宿学校可能并不理想。确实不是。是的，这并不理想。
And so he gets horribly bullied, but he stands up for himself. And rather like Tom Brown, Dominic, he stands up for all the other boys as well. So he's full of pluck. Oh, brilliant. But he probably doesn't do the praying and stuff that Tom Brown does. No, he doesn't do that. He doesn't do that. And then age 15, very un-Tom Brown, he develops a massive pash. A pash? A pash. Tom, you're the first person in about 40 years to use the word pash. I know. It just seems the appropriate word.
所以他受到了可怕的欺凌，但他站出来反抗。而且多米尼克，就像汤姆·布朗一样，他也为其他所有男孩挺身而出。所以他很有勇气。哦，太棒了。但他可能不像汤姆·布朗那样做祈祷之类的事情。不，他不做那些。他不那样做。然后15岁时，非常不像汤姆·布朗，他产生了一种强烈的迷恋。迷恋？一种迷恋。汤姆，你是大约40年来第一个使用“迷恋”这个词的人。我知道。这似乎是恰当的词。
Right. For an 11-year-old boy, Lord Clare. And the memory of this stays with Byron for the rest of his life. And in fact, in 1821, while they're in Italy, their coaches pass each other and Byron is absolutely unsettled by it. They kind of meet and talk for five minutes and he rushes back and writes in his journal, I never hear the word Clare without a beating of the heart, even now. So does anything happen between him and this Lord Clare? It's just kind of, he has a crush on him, basically.
没错。对于一个11岁的男孩，克莱尔勋爵。这种记忆伴随了拜伦余生。事实上，在1821年，当他们在意大利时，他们的马车擦肩而过，拜伦对此感到非常不安。他们见面谈了五分钟，他冲回去在日记中写道，即使现在，我听到“克莱尔”这个词，心跳依然会加速。那么他和这位克莱尔勋爵之间发生了什么吗？基本上就是他迷恋他。
Yeah, I don't think so. But I mean, I think there are all kinds of schoolboyish crushes going on. And Byron will remember Harrow as a home, a world, a paradise to me, in the way that lots of romantic private school boys do. They remember it as a kind of Eden from which they get exiled. Right. And I think that a further reason why Byron remembers it as a paradise is that once he has left Harrow and gone out into the wide world, he keeps his tastes for boys. But of course, this is now much more dangerous. And it's something that in the traditional biographies of Byron was always suppressed. It was part of what his friends wanted of edit out of the story. But I think it's pretty fundamental. And all kinds of texts over the course of the past few hundred years have been found
是的，我不这么认为。但我的意思是，我认为当时有很多学校里的迷恋。拜伦会把哈罗公学记作一个家，一个世界，一个对我来说的天堂，就像许多浪漫的私立学校男孩一样。他们把它记作一个他们被放逐出的伊甸园。没错。我认为拜伦把它记作天堂的另一个原因是，一旦他离开哈罗进入广阔的世界，他依然保持着对男孩的喜好。但当然，这现在危险多了。这是拜伦的传统传记中一直被压制的内容。这是他的朋友们想要从故事中删掉的一部分。但我认为这非常根本。在过去几百年里，各种各样的文本被发现
that demonstrate pretty conclusively that Byron's tastes were definitely homosexual. And there was a groundbreaking book that came out in the 70s, Byron and Greek Love, which, I mean, it emphasises, but also emphasizes how dangerous it was because the backdrop of the Napoleonic Wars has led the British very strongly to identify homosexuality with Jacobinism, Napoleon, all kinds of filthy rot like that. And so, um, basically if you're caught having a gay affair no matter how upper class you are you risk being put in the pillory kind of beaten up or hanged and this is a kind of shadow that hangs over byron from the moment he leaves school right so he has this shadow hanging over him but
这相当确凿地证明了拜伦的喜好绝对是同性恋。70年代出了一本开创性的书，《拜伦与希腊之爱》，它强调了这一点，但也强调了它有多危险，因为拿破仑战争的背景导致英国人强烈地将同性恋与雅各宾主义、拿破仑以及所有这类肮脏的腐败联系在一起。所以，基本上，如果你被抓到有同性恋行为，无论你的阶级有多高，你都有可能被示众、殴打或绞死，这就是拜伦离开学校后一直笼罩在他身上的阴影。没错，所以他身上笼罩着这种阴影，但是
it's not all bad because of course cambridge Cambridge awaits. And the Byrons go to Trinity College. So Byron goes off to Trinity College. And basically, he loves that as well. I mean, he's loved Harrow. He loves Cambridge. He gets to wear a fancy robe covered in gold because he's a peer. So he loves that. They have different gowns if they're peers. Yeah. Really? You get a special one. I don't know whether that's still the case. Maybe if we have any Cambridge undergraduate members of the peerage. Love to know that. I mean, he cuts a tremendous dash.
这并不全是坏事，因为当然，剑桥在等着他。拜伦一家去了三一学院。所以拜伦去了三一学院。基本上，他也喜欢那里。我的意思是，他喜欢哈罗。他喜欢剑桥。他可以穿上一件镶金的华丽长袍，因为他是贵族。所以他喜欢那个。如果他们是贵族，他们有不同的长袍。真的吗？你会得到一件特别的。我不知道现在是否还是这样。也许如果我们有任何剑桥大学的贵族本科生会员。很想知道。我的意思是，他看起来非常显眼。
He turns up for freshers week and writes to Hanson, dear sir, I will be obliged to you to order me down four dozen of wine, port, sherry, claret and Madeira, one dozen of each. So Hanson is the guy running his estate? Yes, the lawyer. So he's still dependent on Hanson? Well, Hanson is his lawyer. Okay. So he's the guy who Hanson. Well, Hanson is his lawyer. Okay. So he's the guy who's responsible for fixing things.
他在新生周出现，并写信给汉森，亲爱的先生，请务必为我订购四打葡萄酒，波特酒、雪利酒、红葡萄酒和马德拉酒，每种一打。所以汉森是经营他庄园的人？是的，律师。所以他仍然依赖汉森？嗯，汉森是他的律师。好吧。所以他是那个汉森。嗯，汉森是他的律师。好吧。所以他是那个负责解决问题的人。
Right. Byron, by now, he's a peer. He's getting a taste for hard living. You know, he's not going to obey college rules. He's told that he can't have a dog. So he famously brings in a bear, installs a bear in the college. And he, in the kind of the very heady romantic way of young men in this period, and right the way through the next two centuries, who go to Oxford or Cambridge, he develops very,
没错。拜伦，现在他是一名贵族。他开始喜欢上奢靡的生活。你知道，他不会遵守学院的规矩。他被告知不能养狗。所以他很有名地带进了一只熊，在学院里安置了一只熊。而且他，以那个时期年轻男子那种非常令人兴奋的浪漫方式，以及在接下来的两个世纪里，去牛津或剑桥的人，他发展出了非常
very close friendships. And these are friends who will be a part of his life for a long time. The most important of these friends is a man called John Cam Hobhouse, who is actually very serious, very sober, from a radical dissenting background. So not the kind of person who would obviously hang out with a hard living peer. And to begin with, they hate each other, but they end up, I mean, Hobhouse will be Byron's closest friend throughout his life. I guess because they're both outsiders, they're both conscious of being outsiders. Yes, I think so. I think so. Yes yes but i think also they come to share so many experiences yeah and that the other one is a man called charles skinner matthews who has two very
非常亲密的友谊。这些朋友将长期成为他生活的一部分。这些朋友中最重要的是一个叫约翰·卡姆·霍布豪斯的人，他实际上非常严肃、清醒，来自一个激进的异见背景。所以不是那种显然会和过着奢靡生活的贵族混在一起的人。起初，他们互相讨厌，但最终，我的意思是，霍布豪斯将成为拜伦一生中最亲密的朋友。我猜是因为他们都是局外人，他们都意识到自己是局外人。是的，我想是这样。我想是这样。是的，是的，但我认为他们也分享了许多经历，是的，另一个人是一个叫查尔斯·斯金纳·马修斯的人，他有两个非常
telling nicknames one of them is citizen which is kind of you know the regency equivalent of comrade yes of course matthews is he's an atheist he's a republican you know and this is a time where expressing atheist or republican views could really get you in trouble. But so also, you know, as we've said, sodomy can get you in trouble as well. And Matthew's other nickname is the Methodist. And his homosexuality, so Charles Skinner Matthews, that would be well known to his friends. It wouldn't be hidden from them. Yeah. Be well known to his friends. Kind of, you know, a bit like Sebastian Flight in Brideshead Revisited. Yeah. It's that kind of... If you know the code, if you're part of the group, if you know the code. Yeah, exactly. Do you fancy a bit of Methodism that kind of absolutely and it's pretty clear i think that i mentioned sebastian flight byron in his second year comes back and he is transformed
说明性的绰号，其中一个是“公民”，这有点像，你知道，摄政时代的“同志”的等价物。是的，当然。马修斯是一个无神论者，他是一个共和主义者，你知道，这是一个表达无神论或共和主义观点真的会让你陷入麻烦的时代。但正如我们所说，鸡奸也会让你陷入麻烦。马修斯的另一个绰号是“卫理公会教徒”。他的同性恋倾向，也就是查尔斯·斯金纳·马修斯，他的朋友们都很清楚。这对他来说不会是隐藏的。是的。他的朋友们都很清楚。有点像，你知道，有点像《故园风雨后》里的塞巴斯蒂安·弗莱特。是的。就是那种……如果你懂暗号，如果你是群体的一部分，如果你懂暗号。是的，完全正确。你想来点卫理公会教义吗？那种绝对是，而且我认为很清楚，我提到了塞巴斯蒂安·弗莱特，拜伦在第二年回来时，他已经变身了
into an unbelievably handsome figure so before that he'd been a bit overweight and he becomes obsessed by losing it so he sets up in a gym with gentleman john jack, who had been champion of all England from 1798 to 1803. And he also goes on an absolute starvation diet. And I think he basically becomes bulimic. Oh, really? Yeah. He's very, very obsessed by diet.
成了一个难以置信的英俊人物，所以在那之前他有点超重，他变得痴迷于减肥，所以他和绅士约翰·杰克一起开了一家健身房，后者曾是1798年至1803年全英冠军。他还进行了绝对的节食。我想他基本上变得贪食了。哦，真的吗？是的。他非常、非常痴迷于饮食。
He has all kinds of weird phobias about it. For instance, he can't bear to watch a woman eat. It's kind of very weird. But over the course of his time at Cambridge, he loses almost four stone. Crikey. And I think at this point, his gay identity is incredibly important to him. Yeah. And so he has this great love affair.
他对此有各种奇怪的恐惧症。例如，他无法忍受看着女人吃东西。这有点非常奇怪。但在剑桥期间，他减掉了近四英石。天哪。我认为在这一点上，他的同性恋身份对他来说非常重要。是的。所以他有一段伟大的恋情。
And it's with a choir boy called John Edelston, who is two years younger than Byron at this point. So 16. So Byron is 18 and this guy is 16. Yeah. Okay. And it's said that Byron rescued him from drowning in the cam. Whether that's true or not, we don't know. But Byron is completely devoted to him. He claims later in life that it was a
对象是一个叫约翰·埃德尔斯顿的唱诗班男孩，他当时比拜伦小两岁。所以16岁。所以拜伦18岁，这家伙16岁。是的。好吧。据说拜伦把他从剑河里救了出来。这是否属实，我们不知道。但拜伦对他非常忠诚。他后来在生活中声称这是一段
violent though pure love and passion. We don't know whether it was. But what is certainly the case is that when Edelson's voice breaks, Byron's passion slightly fades and he goes and finds him a job in the city as an apprentice clerk. Okay. So that is, it's a thing for boys, not for men. Is that right? Yeah, absolutely. Okay. I'm not going to say anything. I mean, listeners can draw their own conclusions. No. So that is an aspect that would, you know, would raise eyebrows in the 21st century. Yeah, absolutely. And you can see why Byron is nervous about it. Yeah. And I think that because of that,
激烈但纯洁的爱与激情。我们不知道是否如此。但可以肯定的是，当埃德尔斯顿变声后，拜伦的热情稍微减退了，他去帮他在城里找了一份学徒文员的工作。好吧。所以那是，那是针对男孩的，不是针对男人的。是这样吗？是的，绝对是。好吧。我什么都不说了。我的意思是，听众可以得出他们自己的结论。不。所以这是一个在21世纪会引起人们侧目的方面。是的，绝对是。你可以看出为什么拜伦对此感到紧张。是的。我认为正因为如此，
when he leaves Cambridge, he kind of becomes aggressively heterosexual. So he writes to Matthew saying, I've plunged into an abyss of sensuality. And he's talking about women, not boys at that point. But it's absolutely typical that he has a particular affair with a young prostitute called Caroline. He installs her in his rooms in London. But when she goes with him to Brighton, which of course is the most fashionable place in England at the time, made famous by the Prince Regent, he dresses her up as a boy and passes her off as his brother Gordon.
当他离开剑桥时，他变得具有攻击性的异性恋。所以他写信给马修说，我已经陷入了感官的深渊。他当时指的是女人，而不是男孩。但他与一个叫卡罗琳的年轻妓女有特殊的恋情是非常典型的。他把她安置在伦敦的房间里。但当她和他一起去布莱顿，当然那是当时英国最时尚的地方，由摄政王成名，他把她打扮成男孩，并谎称她是他的兄弟戈登。
Okay, that's pretty peculiar behaviour. So again, there's the kind of hint of incest there. Yeah. I mean, let's be honest. At this point, he is somebody who, if you were describing that personality and that upbringing today, I mean, I know it's a silly thing to do, but if you did, you would say of him, he's somebody who's completely messed up.
好吧，那是相当奇特的行为。所以再次，那里有一种乱伦的暗示。是的。我的意思是，让我们诚实一点。在这一点上，他是一个人，如果你今天描述那种个性和那种成长经历，我的意思是，我知道这样做很傻，但如果你做了，你会说他是一个完全搞砸了的人。
He's had the most terrible upbringing that has really messed him up. Yeah. And he is now, to some degree, reproducing... The patterns of him. He's somebody who's completely messed up. He's had the most terrible upbringing that has really messed him up. And he is now, to some degree, reproducing- The patterns of behavior. Yeah, the patterns of behavior, the abuse that he has suffered. I mean, that guy, Edelston, by the way, was an orphan, wasn't he? So I mean, there's no way I think of dressing that up and it looking anything other than very, very dodgy. Well, I suppose you could say in Byron's defense, he's very generous. I mean, Edelson's an orphan. He doesn't have anyone to look after him. It gives him lots of money, sets him up with a job. We had this conversation about Oscar Wilde, didn't we?
他有着最糟糕的成长经历，这真的把他搞砸了。是的。他现在在某种程度上正在复制……他的模式。他是一个完全搞砸了的人。他有着最糟糕的成长经历，这真的把他搞砸了。他现在在某种程度上正在复制——行为模式。是的，行为模式，他所遭受的虐待。我的意思是，那个家伙，埃德尔斯顿，顺便说一句，是个孤儿，不是吗？所以我的意思是，我认为没有办法掩饰这一点，让它看起来除了非常、非常可疑之外别无他物。好吧，我想你可以为拜伦辩护，他非常慷慨。我的意思是，埃德尔斯顿是个孤儿。他没有人照顾他。他给了他很多钱，帮他找了份工作。我们之前谈过奥斯卡·王尔德，不是吗？
Yeah. Where do you stand when you look at those kinds of relationships? Do you say this is exploitative and there is a massive power dynamic? Or do you say, actually, there's generosity here, there is genuine affection, and the other person is gaining lots from it? It's hard to know where to stand. Yeah. I think that as with Wilde, say with Byron, the aspects of his life that appalled the Victorians are not necessarily what appalled us, but there are aspects that are morally troubling to both the Victorians and to people in the 21st century, and which continues to give him this kind of selfless quality.
是的。当你审视那种关系时，你的立场是什么？你是说这是剥削性的，存在巨大的权力动态？还是说，实际上，这里有慷慨，有真诚的感情，而另一个人从中获得了很多？很难知道立场在哪里。是的。我认为就像王尔德一样，比如拜伦，他生活中那些让维多利亚时代人感到震惊的方面并不一定是我们感到震惊的，但有些方面对维多利亚时代人和21世纪的人来说在道德上都是令人不安的，这继续赋予他这种无私的品质。
So you say he's messed up. I mean, he's also massively in debt. So he's been renting out Newstead all this time to try and raise cash, and he's been renting it to a guy who seems to have come on to Byron. They have a massive falling out. He kicks this guy out, goes back to Newstead and kind of has a brilliantly gothic time. He invites all his friends. They drink Madeira out of cups that are made out of the monk's skulls. They practice their shooting in the main hall of Newstead. But he's running so badly out of money that he thinks, I'm going to
所以你说他搞砸了。我的意思是，他也负债累累。所以他一直把纽斯特租出去以筹集现金，他把它租给了一个似乎对拜伦有意思的家伙。他们大吵了一架。他把这家伙踢了出去，回到纽斯特，度过了一段精彩的哥特式时光。他邀请了他所有的朋友。他们用僧侣头骨做的杯子喝马德拉酒。他们在纽斯特的大厅里练习射击。但他缺钱缺得太厉害了，以至于他想，我
have to sell it. And the other thing that's worrying him, which of course is something that worries everybody when they leave universities, what are you going to do with your life? He's been a big name on campus. Great things are expected of him, but what? So the obvious thing would be politics. He's a peer, so he can sit in the House of Lords and he takes his seat. Right. So he's automatically a politician if he wants to be. Yeah. Yeah. so he takes his seat in March 1809. And I guess by instinct, he would incline to the Whigs. So Britain at this time is governed by the Tories.
将不得不卖掉它。另一件让他担心的事情，当然是每个人离开大学时都会担心的事情，你打算用你的生命做什么？他在校园里是个大人物。人们对他期望很高，但做什么呢？所以显而易见的事情是政治。他是一名贵族，所以他可以在上议院就座，他占据了他的席位。没错。所以如果他愿意，他自动就是一名政治家。是的。是的。所以他在1809年3月占据了他的席位。我猜凭直觉，他会倾向于辉格党。所以当时的英国由托利党统治。
They're fighting a war. It's a pretty repressive form of government. Lots of civil liberties have been suspended. Byron strongly identifies with the more radical wing of the Whigs, the kind of Whigs who actually pretty much support Napoleon. They love the French Revolution and they love Napoleon. There's kind of Charles James Fox, you know, let's all worship at the altar of France, that kind of thing.
他们正在打仗。这是一种相当压迫性的政府形式。许多公民自由被暂停了。拜伦强烈认同辉格党中更激进的一派，那种实际上相当支持拿破仑的辉格党。他们热爱法国大革命，他们热爱拿破仑。有查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯那种，你知道，让我们都在法国的祭坛前崇拜，那种东西。
Yeah. But Byron, although he kind of sides with them, he doesn't want to identify with them basically because he's too egocentric, too lordly, too independent. You know, he doesn't want to have his individuality subsumed within a party system. You can't imagine him being a party man, can you? No, he's absolutely not. And so he delays giving his maiden speech. The other career, perhaps, is that as a poet. So he's been writing poetry throughout his time at Cambridge, and he publishes a collection of these poems in 1807 when he's 19, calls it Hours of Idleness. And he publishes this, at the head of it, he kind of writes this introduction where he basically says,
是的。但拜伦，尽管他站在他们一边，但他基本上不想认同他们，因为他太以自我为中心，太傲慢，太独立了。你知道，他不希望自己的个性被纳入政党体系。你无法想象他会是一个政党人，对吧？不，他绝对不是。所以他推迟了发表他的处女演讲。另一种职业，也许是诗人。所以他在剑桥期间一直在写诗，他在1807年19岁时出版了一本这些诗的合集，称之为《闲暇的时光》。他出版了这个，在它的开头，他写了这篇介绍，基本上说，
you know, I must plead my minority. I'm just a young man. Have these trifles. And everyone is very polite about them because, you know, he's a peer and he's very young. But the Edinburgh Review, which is a Whig publication, and so byron would have expected it to be supportive i mean just tears into him gives him one of the all-time terrible reviews in the history of english literature well byron is in good company there because there are other people in history who have had disobliging reviews from scottish newspapers yes of course and And you will recall that there was a brilliant production of the play Beckett in Scotland
你知道，我必须为我的未成年辩护。我只是个年轻人。拿去这些琐事吧。每个人对它们都非常有礼貌，因为，你知道，他是个贵族，而且非常年轻。但《爱丁堡评论》，这是一份辉格党出版物，所以拜伦本以为它会支持他，我的意思是，简直把他撕碎了，给了他英国文学史上最糟糕的评论之一。好吧，拜伦在那里有很好的陪伴，因为历史上还有其他人从苏格兰报纸那里得到过不讨好的评论。是的，当然。而且你会记得，在苏格兰有一部精彩的戏剧《贝克特》
in the 1990s that received a one-star review from the Scotsman. And I was playing the lead, would you believe? Right. And the impact of that devastating review on you. Yeah. Well, actually, that Byron comparison, which has often been made between the two of us. So Byron's response was to drink three bottles of claret and then to dash off a vituperative satire on the literary scene, which he called English bards and Scotch reviewers. And so he's not just attacking the people at the Edinburgh Review.
在1990年代，它收到了《苏格兰人报》的一星评论。而我当时在演主角，你敢相信吗？没错。那篇毁灭性的评论对你的影响。是的。好吧，实际上，那种拜伦的比较，经常在我们两人之间被提及。所以拜伦的反应是喝了三瓶红葡萄酒，然后匆忙写下了一篇关于文学界的恶毒讽刺，他称之为《英国诗人和苏格兰评论家》。所以他不仅在攻击《爱丁堡评论》的人。
He's also basically attacking every famous poet in Britain, which Fiona McCarthy in her great biography of Byron, Byron Life and Legend, describes as an almost manic act of courage because he's basically taking on the entire literary establishment. So basically, his literary career isn't going well. And adding to the problem is that he kind of despises poets. They're not people getting out there and doing things. They're not shaping the fate of nations. They're not Napoleon. They just scribble away. Because he's like so many people, Tom, does he live in the shadow of nations they're not napoleon yeah you know they just scribble away because he's like so many people tom does he live in the shadow of napoleon because lots of people do in this period they think napoleon is a self-made man he's the kind of person who didn't exist before he's the ultimate romantic hero and i i mean you see this so much in i don't know the red and the
他基本上还在攻击英国的每一位著名诗人，菲奥娜·麦卡锡在她伟大的拜伦传记《拜伦：生活与传奇》中将其描述为一种近乎狂躁的勇气行为，因为他基本上是在挑战整个文学界。所以基本上，他的文学事业并不顺利。更糟糕的是，他有点鄙视诗人。他们不是那种走出去做事的人。他们不是在塑造国家的命运。他们不是拿破仑。他们只是乱涂乱画。因为他像很多人一样，汤姆，他生活在国家的阴影下，他们不是拿破仑，是的，你知道，他们只是乱涂乱画，因为他像很多人一样，汤姆，他生活在拿破仑的阴影下吗？因为在这个时期很多人都这样，他们认为拿破仑是一个白手起家的人，他是那种以前不存在的人，他是终极的浪漫英雄，而且我，我的意思是，你在司汤达的《红与黑》中看到了很多，伟大的法国小说，而且司汤达遇到了拜伦，哦，真的吗？是的，我可以想象他们会相处得很好。好吧，所以这种感觉，我不认为人们之前有过很多，一种因为他们不是拿破仑而产生的不胜任感，拜伦有这种感觉吗？
black by stondahl great french novel and stondahl meets byron oh really yeah i can imagine they would get on very well well so this sort of sense which I don't think people have massively had before a sense of inadequacy because they're not Napoleon does Byron have this?
好吧，我的意思是，在英国，到目前为止，拿破仑简直就是那个妖怪，是的，但拜伦在英雄崇拜的程度上是不寻常的
well I mean in Britain by now Napoleon is well literally the bogey yes but he's Byron is unusual in the degree of hero worship
他表现出来的，所以作为一个在哈罗的男孩，他有一个拿破仑的半身像，并保护它免受那些试图砸碎它的人的伤害，而且他总是。所以作为一个在哈罗的男孩，他有一个拿破仑的半身像，并保护它免受那些试图砸碎它的人的伤害。而且他总是对拜伦有一种偏爱，显然确实认同他。而且我认为这都是导致，你知道，到1809年，他19岁时，他真的不知道该拿自己怎么办的动荡的一部分。
that he shows so as a boy at Harrow he had had a bust of Napoleon and had defended it against people who'd been trying to smash it and he always. So as a boy at Harrow, he had had a bust of Napoleon and had defended it against people who'd been trying to smash it. And he always kind of has a soft spot for Byron, clearly kind of does identify with him. And I think that this is all part of the churn that means that, you know, by 1809, he's 19. He doesn't really know what to do with himself.
他被债务困扰。他担心自己会因为性取向而被捕，要么被绞死，要么被示众。他真的不想进入政界，真的不想闲逛并成为一个乱涂乱画的人。所以他决定出国，逃避他的职业焦虑、他的金钱烦恼、逃避他对英国道德压迫性的感觉。当他决定这样做的那一刻，他立刻变得更开朗了。他决定去那个一直萦绕在他想象中的地方，也就是东方。1809年7月2日，拜伦前往西南部的法尔茅斯。他乘船前往葡萄牙，这将是他东方冒险的第一步。好吧，太棒了，真是个悬念，汤姆，如果人们想加入拜伦勋爵的那次冒险
He's harried by debts. He's worried that he's going to get arrested and either hanged or put in the pillory for his sexuality. He doesn't really want to go into politics, doesn't really want to kind of hang around and be a scribbler. And so he decides to go abroad, escape his career anxieties, his money worries, escape his sense of the oppressive character of English morality. And the moment he decides to do this, he immediately becomes more cheerful. He decides that he will go to the place that has always haunted his imaginings, which is the Orient. On the 2nd of July 1809, Byron heads down to the southwest, to Falmouth. He takes ship to Portugal, and this will be the first step on his eastern adventure. Well brilliant what a cliffhanger Tom and if people want to join Lord Byron on that adventure
马上，为了让你尝尝即将发生的事情，他要去半岛战争中的葡萄牙，亚瑟·韦尔斯利爵士，未来的威灵顿公爵正在与拿破仑的军队作战，他要去马耳他，去阿尔巴尼亚，去希腊，去君士坦丁堡。他会见到苏丹，不是吗，汤姆？是这样吗？他见到了苏丹。所以有很多戏剧性，有很多色彩即将到来。你当然可以现在就听那个。你所要做的就是加入《历史余谈》俱乐部，享受它带来的所有闪闪发光的福利和装饰品。是的，是的，那本身就是一种异国情调的幻想，不是吗，《历史余谈》俱乐部，你可以通过访问
right away just to give you a taste of what is coming he's going to Portugal in the middle of the Peninsular War, Sir Arthur Wellesley the future Duke of Wellington fighting against Napoleon's forces, he's going to Malta, to Albania, to Greece, to Constantinople. He'll meet the Sultan, won't you, Tom? Is that right? He meets the Sultan. So lots of drama, lots of colour to come. You can, of course, listen to that right now. All you have to do is join the Rest is History Club with all the glittering benefits and baubles that that brings you. Yeah yeah that's a kind of an exotic fantasy in its own right isn't it the rest is history club and you can join that by going to
therestishistory.com 加入，如果不是，如果你是一个琐碎的、维多利亚时代那种人，你只想等待下一集，带着所有的广告。没问题。请便。你只需要等到下次。但有什么乐趣和款待在等着我们呢，嗯，汤姆？绝对是。我们下次见。再见。再见。
the rest is history.com if not if you're a petty fogging pooterish victorian kind of person you just want to wait for the next episode with all the ads. Fair enough. Be my guest. You'll just have to wait till next time. But what delights and treats are in store for us, eh, Tom? Absolutely. We'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》，这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
在问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外剧集
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。